when you slapped uh korean zombies
manager who's
uh no it was friends
[Laughter]
chin's friends with him and chin was
like can you believe ryan did that i'll
go [ __ ] yeah like right
stop talking about it brandon you're
friends
is he not his manager he just deals with
his social media you don't have to talk
about everything
i was just saying like to me that's all
that was the other that's out of
character for you to do that yeah
it was knowing you like that was out of
character if you had
any idea of what my week was like that
week
you would understand like stress just
sit like
i don't know if tikki's getting mad if i
speak right now
who who's game tj thank you but that
provides some context that we didn't
know
like you know hey put it this way i got
in a fight
on a tuesday i got in a fight on a
friday
some crazy [ __ ] happened on a thursday
so you're just
i was on a bomb on that one and then you
saw him yeah and i wasn't getting in
trouble like to the point where like
it's
like some [ __ ] happened uh
in vegas and [ __ ] like right the
friday before that fight
got him got a fight uh
[ __ ] cops had had his like belly down
and [ __ ] and the guy looks at me like
brian like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] do you
i just i can't think i just gotta act
right i'm like oh
my career like i see again i see four
guys on you that have
something yeah we are uh trained not to
think
yeah i mean like you think you lose but
then when you unleash that [ __ ] inside
of you and you
then you see the aftermath you're like
[ __ ] yeah and then the cops don't want
to see what happened
dude
[Laughter]
but the cops saw me let me go which was
good nice and then
uh yeah i was already see not all cops
guys not all cops
and uh so yeah and then i [ __ ]
told the homeboy if i saw him i'd slap
him
because he was controlling his social
media right he was at the end like when
i talked to korean zombies said he
wasn't whatever
i think it was just a misunderstanding
misunderstanding i don't know i like
that i like yeah i like those guys
but i just felt like bro like in my
opinion was like just stay out of it
like the fight's already happening
we're not getting pay-per-view buyers
yeah we're
like i went to korea i showed nothing
but love over there i was
respectful even when he told me like hey
dude it was my team yep
and i said [ __ ] like it is like [ __ ] it
bro like just yeah we don't have to be
[ __ ] every fight
to each other to promote it like i think
we're two good fighters
it's not your nature it's not natural
for you so when this little guy like
when this guy starts kind of acting up
on social media
and like kind of like in my the way i
took it was like he's kind of puffing
his chest i'm like hold up [ __ ]
like you're not a regular guy
he's a rapper where where uh
like if someone talks [ __ ] okay but if
like bro we're
we're going to run into each other yeah
i'm going to see you yeah
it's not like something inside yeah and
it's like i'm and i'm nice with everyone
yeah i don't have issues with anyone
rather than even volcanos whatever like
i don't have issues with anyone yeah
so i was like bro just stop that [ __ ]
and he still kind of kept fighting all
right [ __ ] like
yeah wait till i see you yeah and then i
i didn't even know he was there until
like i looked back and i was like
[ __ ] he's there i swear that's what ran
through my head i was like
[ __ ] like i'm been already in the world
of [ __ ] from this week
we're like well i guess i get a slab
again and that's what i told myself [ __ ]
dude i can't like i have to be mad
too i promised myself and i almost and i
didn't even want to either like and i
walked up like i jumped over the chair
and i was just like
look i don't want to do this and i still
didn't realize i still didn't even i
wasn't even sure if it was him or not
yeah and i said hey [ __ ] what's
your [ __ ] name korean people
no no yeah
you have to ask his name i was just like
hey [ __ ] what's your name
yeah if you would be like hey bro
relax i want to [ __ ] did [ __ ] yeah
but i want to do but he was just like
like he was like oh like jay park like
the way he said i go oh yeah
[ __ ] like all right
and then it was like [ __ ] all right that
just happened
but if you're gonna do it's probably the
best place to do it yeah